remember this guy
yes it's Colin Furze the British
inventor and stuntman who previously
wowed our experts with his homemade wall
of death but Colin hasn't been resting
on his laurels he has a newer and much
louder obsession jet engines
okay let's build a massive post chair
Wow
yes he's been building something even
more dangerous even more impressive and
even more insane post my sensible things
data behold a jet bike a 10-foot long
liquid propane driven pulse jet engine
on an old bicycle we trapped calling
down to find out what's behind his
dangerous mix of Jets and bicycles in a
way they kind of useless today produce
much for us to just get hot make a lot
of noise but there's something about
that she's just amazing so it built this
chuffing great pulse jet and fire this
bike laying around so why not put the
two together why not indeed Carlin was
ready to ride and two million of us
tuned in to see him take his bike to the
limit
I'm sure whoever designed that bicycle
never imagined wildest dreams that the
pulse-jet would be hooked up to it
that is there's a cool noise there's a
noise that people will hear coming and
they will turn and look to see what it
is and it's you it's in such a bizarre
feeling you've got his epic noise behind
it and can't hear anything you can't
speak to anybody just how scared two
people look it certainly looks like back
if I turn it off Talyn hit over 50 miles
per hour so how does a simple pulse jet
allow an old bike to reach ludicrous
speed he's built the the simplest type
of jet engine which is called a pulse
jet engine it is literally a bent tube
there were no moving parts so you have
three basic components you have your
exhaust which is the long long portion
and then you have your combustion
chamber and then you have your intake
the fuel is introduced into the
combustion chamber that fuel that seeps
out through the exhaust and he likes it
when they first set the fuel on fire
you see a large orange flame come out
the back this is because there's not
enough oxygen in the pipe for all the
fuel to burn to fix this
Colin uses a leaf blower the leaf blower
is effectively the same as the turbine
in a normal jet engine he can force a
lot of air bringing a lot of oxygen into
the combustion chamber so that all of
the fuel burns completely and forces the
bike forward but no one's trailing with
a leaf blower what's going on
whenever the fuel combusts it expands
rapidly but after it's burnt all the
fuel it goes so far it actually creates
a low pressure in the combustion chamber
this means air from the air inlet it's
gonna get sucked in gas is gonna be
allowed in from his throttle control and
also air is gonna be sucked back by the
exhaust pipe however since the exhaust
pipe is a bit longer some of those hot
combusted gases are still trapped in
that pipe so when they come back they're
still hot they will fire the next one
and you just get this continuous rolling
combustion which gives the jet the first
these explosions are happening 250 times
a second and they're loud explosions so
it's loud it's powerful it's cool